[Applause]
King Comcast 40 seconds of logos
everything you have we had it and did it
better condescend narration me I'm Ryan
Pierce successful author thesis the
intros and backstories of these women
are so scattershot that I might as well
be watching Suicide Squad how do you
hook up with the second coming of Oprah
Ryan strength has always been making
others their best selves my cinnamon at
all doesn't even come close to actually
answering the question
classy Posse was there to witness wait I
thought we had already jumped ahead to
2004 with Deena and 2011 with Lisa now
we're back to 2002 Jesus movie pick a
timeline the essence folks just called
they want you to be the keynote speaker
this year and that's when you realize
that the Flossie Posse needs to ride
again tell them I'd be honored luckily
if her essence and movie Ryan was having
this flashback episode just in time to
be invited to an event that could
accommodate her three friends you can
purchase Ryan Pierce's latest New York
Times best seller in New Orleans at
essence vest or I assume you could
purchase it through Amazon or even from
a local bookstore considering it's
already a best-seller
I guess the copywriter got bored and
started playing around with a
combination of these two names but Ryan
Stewart was the best they could do man I
miss the creative salad days of Bennifer
and Brangelina character thinks they put
someone on hold and starts talking about
them only to find out they didn't put
them on hold and they heard every word
cliche bedtime 8:00 p.m. sure I need you
to focus
but she's writing all this down right
sure Lisa's a little OCD but there's no
reason for her to expect her mother to
memorize everything she's saying and
turns out mom lives here anyway so does
she really need this level of
instruction
therefore you are not going off to war
haha I have to take a sin off for
Tiffany Haddish who was one of the best
things about 2017 and yes there are
other places in this movie where she has
better lines but it would basically be
one big bleep so here you go
really what's wrong with this okay I
know Lisa's the supermom character that
doesn't think about fashion but she's
literally wearing her name badge on
these scrubs you're telling me she
wasn't planning on changing clothes for
the trip that's amazing she said her
business very peeps down in New Orleans
this weekend to make the offer even
though Ryan will be tremendously busy at
essence vest and it would be much easier
to call or email that smart has to meet
her in New Orleans so that we can add
some high jinks to this deal Jesus could
they Telegraph that Stewart's a cheatin
bastard any harder at the beginning of
this movie looks like Ryan's agent went
to the Harvey Weinstein School of
Business and sanitizer got my
anti-nausea medication oh Lisa is
required to emphasize her apparently one
character trait by naming all the in her
bag out loud what I mean that case let
me go ahead and get those three shots
now the sequence couldn't get any more
bridesmaids E unless some lame character
was shown wearing a colorful necro own
also why does the flight attendant even
look at Dina weird is a pre-flight
3-shot order even that out of a request
especially in first class asking for a
friend
how long has it been since you got that
back blown out Jesus with all this
badgering it feels like the film is
setting up girls trip to to be about
Lisa becoming a serial killer you're
getting something this weekend right up
you gonna get at least 230 great we can
add needs to get laid - Lisa's fully
fleshed out overworked mom character
also as Lisa really on board with the
whole I gotta get laid drain until her
friends basically bully her into it she
literally said she's happy with what she
has and doesn't express a want or need
for sex but hey I guess that grapefruit
snuck up
deena apparently can make a backing
track appear out of nowhere when she
wants to sing contrary to popular belief
this is not how you accomplished a rusty
trombone they've been in New Orleans for
probably less than an hour and Dena has
already collected all those beads she's
not even in proper flashing attire
[Music]
shadowing is the grammo look I know
Sasha's in the gossip world but she's
able to immediately identify a random
Instagram model and her location from
one photo taken from behind because what
you need while you're drinking a lot is
to totally be spinning around I'm sorry
but that's not the way we do things here
but we are not pressing charges okay
awesome but this is the hotel manager
not the police so why would this affect
their ability to throw teen out but our
brand is we are it's who you are this
works all the four five-star hotels have
booked my Sascha making this call though
Ryan's the keynote speaker at the
essence Fest and they promised her a VIP
package shouldn't she at least check
with them people there are literally two
windows that Ryan could use to see who's
outside the door but let's continue this
tomfoolery for no reason now men of
almost anything but not you in that
outfit movie follows the bad moms we're
all the beautiful women not getting
because of what they choose to wear when
in reality that up that Lisa has on
could be covered in vomit and she would
still have ten dudes lined up especially
in New Orleans my kids and I sent movie
throws in even more bad mom by making
the motherly character completely
unbelievably clueless about how that was
five years ago argue mix position hey
pretty lady from barb extremely very
least you we're gonna run into each
other again but how this isn't home
alone too lost in New York level
coincidence but New Orleans is big
enough that there are enough people
there to make this second meet up next
to impossible ladies look at your man
Scott hold on aren't they already in the
VIP area and even if there's yet another
layer of VI penis why doesn't Ryan have
that already essence itself invited her
ass here also somehow Julian has four
extra backstage passes
could Deena possibly know that yeah I
know that comedies got a comedy but the
fact that this would ever happen on a
heavily trafficked zip line is some bull
that I'm not ready to accept also this
makes no sense
lisa is the tiniest of the crew by far
she should have just zoomed over to the
other side according to physics alone if
anything it would have been more likely
that she'd shot across so fast they
couldn't stop her and she crashed
through a window which would still
provide comedy but with far less Eirik
how was Deena allowed to zipline out
there while Lisa still can hang in there
I know this is New Orleans but there's
got to be some regulation man most of
this movie's wacky but believable but at
this moment we've reached the absurdity
level of a bad Adam Sandler movie also
this is fucking Bourbon Street where you
can easily get arrested for taking a
quick leak in a dark alley but both
Deena and Lisa let loose a fucking
monsoon from a zip line and faces your
repercussions earlier Ryan was accosted
by many people who knew who she wants
and they're currently hanging out in an
extremely crowded area so why hasn't
anyone noticed her getting hammered and
hitting on Julia alright sure the guys
in the band look I'm sure Julian's a
well-respected musician and all but he's
a bassist so why the hell does he get
this enormous suite to himself when the
rest of the bands all staying together
just grapefruit him never before this
sets up a hilariously profane scene but
it's also super goddamn convenient that
Deena brings up the sex act during
breakfast when there's a grapefruit
readily available this scene is
over-the-top and kind of fine but from a
practical standpoint how does this work
exactly it doesn't make the any smaller
when you put the fruit on it and what
happens later in the movie when this
inevitably happens is what would happen
every time you try to put a citrus fruit
on a man's junk mean this movie's not
even trying to hide the constant plot
conveniences here not only does the
Instagram girl show up at the perfect
time Carla immediately invites her up on
stage but I could use some extra sausage
what's this woman's deal she's been
sneaking around with Stuart this whole
time but now she decided to actively
provoke Ryan King why well I'm gonna
take this underutilized tool and I'm
gonna put it on this over you the last
sausage
it appears as though the ground
understands that Ryan's talking about
cutting off Stewart's and they're on
board with it if I leaked it you can get
in front of it steered a conversation
instead of letting TMZ write their own
spin on it
what the hell sense does this make TMZ
is gonna write something about this
picture even if it's posted from
somewhere else and if Ryan knows the
pictures gonna come out eventually she
could get ahead of it at any time I got
the best thing this is 200 year old oh
great nobody has time to perpetuate the
Absinthe will make you hallucinate myth
because we haven't gotten enough
shenanigans out of this group already
also I know dude is trying to make money
but this is so rare then why is it the
first thing you want for Deena as if
this movie hasn't ripped off all the
other raunchy comedies enough Deena
essentially pulls the roofie trick from
The Hangover you have a way of bringing
people closer together definitely have a
way of changing how the fuck did she
hear Lisa essentially whispering to Ryan
all the way in the other room over the
music that's playing in the living room
the absinthe hits all the girls at
exactly the same time which is
definitely how drugs work Jesus how many
fucking candles does this table need I
know one was used for comedic effect
earlier but there are 11 additional ones
my card I get that the server is
confused but why would she actually
except the shoot Plan B should be
blaming all this on Deena because it's
100% her fault she attempted to slice
open Stuart's throat committed public
urination all over Bourbon Street tried
to molest Morris Chestnut and now has
poisoned all of her friends this is just
for starters
they're all tripping so hard that Sasha
just trying to collect but somehow they
were able to pick out and purchase wigs
in some classes from a merchant for
their disguises the fact that Deena says
this and it cuts to Queen Latifah and
Jada pinkett-smith who were in 1996 is
set it off is almost sin removal worthy
but the fact that they linger and do
this knowing non thing is indicative of
the potential that's lost in this movie
so goddamn it at this point someone's
got to think she's the one being stomped
just work off I mean did they have this
dance choreographed and ready to go
tonight just in case they ran into a
rival group that also had four members
nothing says sexy dance off like a human
centipede so did the flossy posse win is
it all how are these things subdued ax
cated this is Tina she has a condition
of never realizing when she's been
served
but this fights been going on like 40
seconds and the cops are already here
we're released when Tina and Lisa were
dowsing random people in urine last
night my favorite one of them is bad
screenwriting also Lorenz tape works in
an audition tape in the middle of this
movie since he's one of five people in
Hollywood who have yet to be in a Marvel
or DC movie even though the sign by the
door was clearly states that you need a
keycard to reenter after 10 p.m. they
open automatically for Ryan she bought
the boy from them
thanks for hammering me over the head
with this dude's giant movie but I'm
wondering why does she need to the
demonstration Tina gave this morning you
use the fruit as a device to be used in
addition to oral sex so even though this
dude is apparently freakishly and down
the second grapefruit should be useless
3 2 what Dina can somehow time exactly
how fast Lisa can carve and prepare this
grapefruit
[Applause]
why isn't he removing the grapefruit but
I'm talking about Caitlyn Jenner
pregnant my tiger good photos that come
the Sasha having financial troubles
subplot is easily the least interesting
storyline in this movie you to give
people hope that you can have it all and
we want in so we're just gonna ignore
that whole incident last night and even
if Bethany bought that boat but Ryan's
allergy medicine she saw everyone else
up to right water under the bridge
here's an ass ton of money shouldn't
affect that sasha is hanging out with
one of the most powerful women in the
country give her websites and cred I
mean she's been posting this to
Instagram all weekend I'm just you know
working on my craft I realized Julian's
attractive and all but there is no basis
that would get anywhere near this level
of attention I'm pregnant and before you
even insult me
yes it's Stewart's and she just figured
this out she was out of the fucking club
last night drinking and dancing and
brawling but she just happened to take a
pregnancy test this morning on vacation
and she knows it Stewart's do you even
love me anymore okay moving can you make
up your mind about whether this is a
pay-for-play sham marriage or an actual
loving relationship because at this
point I think you're confused
he dick massaged you that week
deena he's my husband he's not some guy
in a bathroom stall now I can try and
explain that they have a big deal with
best Mart and if they split up her
career could be over don't get it you
all can't Kenny you're not in my world
this character's fight before inevitably
reconciling in the third act cliche is
so cliche that I might as well be
watching the secret life of pets this
choice is diminishing you to finishing
me
says the woman who chooses to talk about
people for a living
damn I didn't realize Sasha was on the
cinemasins payroll I wish she'd been
assigned to this movie I quit my job at
The Times to get our website off the
ground only there was way too much of
this psycho drama for a movie the
features two instances of crowd pissing
on the next Real Housewives of girls
trip you have ruined my life see the
reason I can't care about this
relationship is that the central
conflict is factually inaccurate Ryan
knows it Sasha knows it we know it so
can we just follow Dean around for the
rest of the movie and to anyone out
there who have hurt its truly I'm sorry
even if there is a fancy way for a blog
a text a phone that there's a live post
happening why did Brian get it so late
sasha has already done with our apology
this movie has had a serious lack of
crowds especially considering where they
are but when there needs to be an
obstacle inducing traffic jam one
magically appears also what's the rush
I mean I know they want to support Ryan
at her speech they're not stopping her
from triggering a bomb or anything do
they know the movies almost over is that
it I do not have it all in fact my life
is all kind of screwed up I don't mean
to keep harping on the fact that this
movie is bad moms but I'm pretty sure
this is an exact line that Mila Kunis
delivered while on stage at the end of
the movie you're damned to be fair to
Stewart there is no chair or place on
stage for him to sit his ass down
I was Ryan a girl with her own ambitions
and her own dreams Julian has the
dawning realization that the speech is
gonna lead to him getting fucked tonight
I would never hurt you are we still on
this session I want you to be my partner
hang up did Bethenny agree to this she
literally just said that she wanted Ryan
solo for the deal also this is a nice
sentiment and all but I would think Lisa
and Dina feel a little shafted right now
Dina doesn't have a job to go back to
either
I see posse is back and will inevitably
be back again for a girls trip Christmas
that is a beautiful penis over there hey
Dan not only is lisa sexually woke all
of a sudden she picked up a nasty
revenge porn habit
[Music]
how do you hook up with the second
coming of Oprah Ryan strength has always
been making others their best self the
almighty says don't change the subject
just answer the fuckin question how are
you doctor doctor doctor doctor doctor
doctor I feel good I feel great I feel
wonderful
[Music]
man I'm thirsty might as well have some
of this booty sweat I got back in the
night cuz tonight you suckers got served
slap the bass big time